a number of patients who have died in
English hospitals after testing positive
for kovat 19 has now risen to almost
15,000 but there are signs that the rate
is continuing to slow in England another
429 people are confirmed to have died
after testing positive for coronavirus
with the largest number in today's
update 112 in the North West of England
it takes the total number of confirmed
Hospital deaths in England to 14
thousand 829 there have been 12 more
deaths in hospitals in Scotland taking
the total to 915 nine more Hospital
deaths in Wales bringing the total to
584 we're waiting still for an update
from Northern Ireland but as of
yesterday 194 people have died with
coronavirus in hospitals their
correspondent Helen Anne Smith is in the
newsroom and Helen Anne just break down
these figures for us well not the first
thing to say is that these figures on
Monday are sometimes potentially a touch
misleading because we have to which
remember these are not the number of
people who sadly died yesterday they're
the number of people that the hospital
trusts across the UK recorded a reported
to have died yesterday so the numbers
are often a little artificially lower
Monday's purely because obviously
yesterday Sunday probably fewer
administrative staff in over the weekend
so that's worth saying however just to
take the English number as an example at
that jump of 429 deaths that's the
lowest daily jump that we've seen for
three weeks and you'll remember three
weeks ago there was some alarm at the
sheer speed at which the numbers were
rising and so that's certainly a
promising milestone shall we say now we
might be able to hit show you now a
graphic that just shows the cumulative
number of deaths so essentially the
total number of deaths and how they've
been rising and because as we've always
been saying oh just we're saying that
this is showing at the UK totals and we
are still waiting for today's UK total
that gets released by the Department for
Health and Social Care but this is what
we knew up until what we know up until
now and you see that scale there what
we're interested in is the speed
at which those number of deaths are
rising because the speed show us shows
us something about the way that the
disease is spreading and whether we may
be starting to gain some control you'll
notice at the beginning that death toll
doubling every two days then every three
days now it's over here doubling every
12 days so as you can see that's really
slowing down and and what we're also
interested in is looking at the
percentage increase and how much it's
growing each day so for example between
yesterday and the day before here it's
very difficult to tell from the naked
with the naked eye but that's an
increase of roughly four percent if we
take that a week ago just we're saying
not the Mondays because the mondays are
out potentially a touch misleading but
so for example if we take Friday last
week between the 9th and the 10th of
April that percentage increase there was
12% go back a week further again to
between the 2nd and the 3rd and that
percentage increased there 23% worth
saying that the week before we were
looking at figures in the 30s so you
know that's not irrelevant but we have
to always continually stress these are
still big numbers we're talking about
and it's still horrible the experts
advise that we still may be some way off
the peak we've always known that it
would take a good two or three weeks for
any lockdown in position message to
actually have an effect on that death
data but maybe a glimmer of hope yeah
let's hope so
ok Helen Anne thanks very much